Simplifying this expression is really just
2 instances of using the distributive
property. Let's multiply each term inside
this 1st set of parentheses by 3. And we
want to multiply each term within the
2nd set of parentheses by 150. And now
we just multiply within each term to
simplify. And last, but not least, we add
like terms and we end up with a final
answer of 402w + 480n. This is
interesting. We can see finally, now that
everything is simplified, how the number
of nozzles that have been ordered compares
to the number of wipers that have been
ordered. Before, when we just had 84w +
60n, as Grant's total future earnings,
there were clearly more wipers than
nozzles in demand. But now the situation
is reversed. More novels have been ordered
than wipers. This is one of the many
reasons why simplifying expressions is
really, really helpful when we're doing
word problems. When we have things
simplified down as much as we can, we're
able to see what real word situations are
reflected by the math.